[Musique]
10 euros le dessin à cinq je le fais à
sac aujourd'hui exceptionnellement tout
le monde en profite
bonjour ouais ok je prends l'argent
avancé comme ça vous n'allez pas être
déçus vous voyez c'est merci je suis
dans l'art expressif salon c'est ça je
vais vous faire vous faire un truc dans
ce style là en tant que vous faire
quelque chose de précis faut juste pas
trop bouger c'est l'expérience vous
allez peine déçu
c'est gentil 5,3 du monde tourne un
peuple comme ça ok je prends la mesure
des traits
ce sera 15 minutes après
en plus j'ai refusé un spécial pour les
personnes de couleur s'attendent là
ça va pas être déçu là
comment ça vous plaît pas pourquoi
comment
je comprends pas monsieur vie romancée
santoro la ville ma petite soeur mon
père mais ça casse est ce que je veux
c'est vrai mais ce n'est pas le dessin
corovic prête à pleinement volant et je
vous ai fait vous des sages et suivent
de plus je demande gentiment roman mais
ça corrige pas un tourisme un roman mais
sakho vite la vie de ma mère dit vite
avant que l'état ne vous plaît pas vous
plaît laissez pas en plus si vous
regardez regardez maintenant regardez
c'est parce que j'ai pas dit ça qu'est
ce que tous les otages où comment vous
avez vous changé un peu trembler parce
que vous bougiez beaucoup aussi je suis
gentil raymond commerce et du site ou
plus touche de me regarder ce que j'ai
fait le tattoo ceinture proie qu'on
messieurs messieurs c'est une caméra
cachée
regardez internet ça c'est toi toi même
éthique à la fin on est gentil quand la
cause qu on sait bien que piégé qu'on se
baigner comme des bleus savent aussi
[Applaudissements]
franchement franchement il était très
fort